größer toller besser sensationeller der
Video Day 2012 er findet hier auf der
Gamescom stad in der Halle 112 der
absolute Hammer Wahnsinn denn ein Saal
hätte nicht mehr ausgereicht also eine
komplette Messehalle alles was ihr tun
müsst um dabei zu sein Anmelden auf dem
Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung da kriegt ihr dann
eine Mail kurz vor der gamescom wenn ihr
euch angemeldet habt mit einem
individuellen Barcode heißt die
Kontrolle das wird alles viel schneller
gehen denn wir erwarten tausende ja und
wer kommt zum Video der auf gamescom auf
jeden Fall die beiden hier stimmt ja und
natürlich white ti werden dabei sein die
Außenseiter gron also die absoluten
Superstars und natürlich noch viel mehr
und ihr vor allem kommt zum Video der
gamescom Ticket genügt anmelden im Link
hier unterm Video kostet es nichts extra
und dann kann ich nur sagen viel Spaß
und bis dann da
dran